the Voyager 1 space probe is the
furthest man-made object from earth and
the fastest but right now it is moving
towards us relatively speaking this is
the control room for NASA's Deep Space
Network and the scientists here still
listen for the signal of the Voyager is
sending Deep Space Network is is a
collection of antennas around the world
that we use for tracking deep-space
missions we provide commands to the
spacecraft so you know turn left at the
next corner kinds of things right little
more complicated than that permeance
right on turn the instrument off
software updates most important reason
for sending the thing out there is to
get the science data back and so the
instruments are taking visible pictures
infrared pictures measuring particles in
the case of in the case of Voyager we
need to get that data back down and
distribute it to the scientists the Deep
Space Network three stations cover the
whole sky any mission more than thirty
thousand kilometers away from Earth is
visible to at least one station all the
time
geostationary orbit where we keep most
of our communication satellites it's
further away than that we really have
three complexes around the world Madrid
in Spain Goldstone here in California
and the Canberra complex and Australia
we typically don't track things that go
over the pole because the types of
missions that we deal with are in deep
space and tend to be in the ecliptic if
you look at the solar system where the
Sun is and where the planets are that
are revolving around the Sun they all
tend to be more or less in in one plane
that launched along the plane of the
solar system along the ecliptic is the
reason that Voyager is getting closer to
earth right now yes
Voyager is always moving away from the
Sun but sometimes the Earth's orbit
means our planet is traveling in roughly
the same direction only faster so we're
catching up of course we'll get pulled
back in our elliptical orbit so it'll
even out when we go back the other way
in terms of checking in with spacecraft
I think with Voyager for example we
probably downlink from them almost every
day because again there's a lot of good
data but when you're only coming at 160
bits per second it takes a long time to
get that data off the spacecraft the
signal has to be in some sense above the
noise level for us to see it you first
of all just try to filter the noise out
as much as possible just from a
frequency standpoint my my signal
occupies this much
spectrum in frequency I don't want to
let in any more noise than what's there
I want to correlate the signal that's
coming down with what I think that
signal looks like you got to take
advantage of what you know about this
signal and use those characteristics as
best you can to extract it from the
noise Voyager 1 is carrying radioisotope
thermoelectric generators RTGS
it's powered by radioactive decay and
there's enough power there to last until
around 2025 after that the craft will go
dark carrying a message forward into
interstellar space for well we don't
know where or when or even if there is
enough light being bounced off of it you
might be able to see it with a with a
telescope but it's so far away and so
dim without a radio signal coming from
Voyager at all there's no way that we
the DSN would would be tracking it and
so I think that's pretty much the end
once once it goes dark thank you very
much to all the team at NASA the Jet
Propulsion Laboratory and here at the
Deep Space Network pull down the
description for more about them and
about their missions